[Musique]
parce qu'on l'accuse d'être
l'organisateur d'un saccage
c'est en paysans militants que josé bové
se présente aujourd'hui au tribunal de
millau le 12 août dernier une vingtaine
de militants de la confédération
paysanne s'attaque au chantier du
mcdonald's en construction au milieu
pour josé bové qui n'est alors que le
porte-parole aveyronnais du syndicat ce
démontage est une réponse gauloise au
surtaxe sur le roquefort imposé par les
américains mais la justice après 6
pouces cinq jours plus tard quatre
militants sont écroués et josé bové
recherché pour dégradations en réunion
la solidarité s'organise et bientôt la
confédération pelle 105 mille francs de
caution pour chaque militant la réponse
du berger à la justice sonne comme un
nouvel affront josé bové choisi la
présent au nom de la lutte contre la
mondialisation dernier un éleveur de
brebis du larzac emprisonné la france
découvre alors un militant convaincu et
convaincant de l'aveyron à l'amérique
les dons affluent pour sa caution et le
7 septembre
josé bové libéré on peut que remercier à
justice de nous avoir fait cette
répression parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
eu l'écho que qu'on a voulu et qui est
qui va s'amplifier dix mois après les
faits le procès de josé bové et des neuf
autres militants s'ouvre dans une
ambiance surmédiatisé 80 journalistes
ont demandé à assister à l'audience dans
une salle qui ne peut contenir que 50
personnes
le procès sera donc retransmis pour le
public sur un écran vidéo placée dans
une autre salle
un détail médiatique qui n'étonne plus
personne
[Musique]